For this live coding session, I want to make it interactive.
And I'll actually be working from Chrome's debugger and JavaScript console,
once the AJAX request has finished, and my data has been loaded.
To do this, I can put a debugger statement inside the draw a callback function.
To make sure that the AJAX request has completed,
and that my data has been passed to the function.
You can set up any JavaScript debugger,
by the keyword debugger, and end the line with a semicolon.
When Chrome loads the page,
it'll first call our d3.tsv function to load world_cup.tsv.
Once the AJAX request has returned, it
will pass the data file in a JavaScript object to our draw a callback function.
And once our callback function is called, code will execute until it
hits the debugger statement, in which execution would stop, and
it will put us into the Chrome debugger at this exact line.